PETE: OH, BOY, WHAT TO SAY ABOUT
BOTH OF THOSE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOWING HILLS
SUPPORT FOR OUR MILITARY.
HE IS SET TO VISIT WALTER REED
MEDICAL CENTER TODAY.
HE WILL MEET WITH WOUNDED COMBAT
VETS AND WOUNDED WORKERS ON THE
FRONT LINES OF COVID-19.
FORMER WHITE HOUSE POSITION AND
CANDIDATE REARED A ADMIRAL
DR. JOHNNY JACKSON JOINS ME NOW.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING ON
THE PROGRAM.
>> THANK YOU, PETE.
PETE: GOOD MORNING.
THE PRESIDENT GOING TO TALK WITH
COMBAT VETS AND WORKERS.
CAN YOU WHAT HE HAS DONE FOR OUR
MILITARY YOUR REACTION?
>> I THINK IT’S A GREAT THING.
I HAVE BEEN WITH THE PRESIDENT
AND ACCOMPANIED HIM ON THESE
VISITS TO THE WALTER REED
NATIONAL MILITARY MEDICAL CENTER
ON A VARIETY OF OCCASIONS.
I THINK IT’S A GREAT THING THAT
HE DOES TO GET OUT THERE AND
VISIT THOSE GUYS THAT HAVE BEEN
OVER THERE AND DEPLOYED OVERSEAS
THAT ARE INJURED THAT ARE COMING
BACK HOME AND RECUPERATING.
HE GOES UP THERE AND TALK TO THE
STAFF IN THE ICUs AND THE
WARDS AND SAYS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE.
IT’S A WONDERFUL THING THAT HE
DOES.
IS HE VERY SIGN SEAR TO MAKE
SURE HE DOES THAT ON A REGULAR
BASIS.
I’M HAPPY TO SEE THAT HE IS
DOING IT.
PETE: THE MEDIA IS GOING TO RUN
BREATHLESSLY IS THE PRESIDENT
WEARING A MASK OR NOT WEARING
MASK.
YOU KNOW BETTER THAN ANYONE ELSE
THIS GUY IS THE MOST TESTED
PERSON PEOPLE NEXT TO HIM HAVE
TO BE TESTED.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THEIR
OBSESSION WHETHER HE WEARS IT OR
NOT.
>> THEY ARE DRIVING A NARRATIVE
HERE.
THEY TRY TO MAKE THE PRESIDENT
LOOK BAD, OBVIOUSLY, NO MATTER
WHAT HE DOES.
YOU ARE RIGHT, THE PRESIDENT AND
THE TEAM THAT SURROUNDS HIM ARE
AGGRESSIVELY TESTED.
HE WILL GO IN THERE TODAY AND HE
WILL WEAR A MASK WHEN IT’S
APPROPRIATE AND HE WILL TO THE
DIRECTION OF THE HOSPITAL
COMMANDER.
YOU KNOW, WE ALL WEAR MASK WHEN
WE GO INTO A HOSPITAL.
I VISIT RURAL HOSPITALS HERE.
I GENERALLY DON’T WEAR A MASK
MOST OF THE THINGS I DO
THROUGHOUT THE DAY BUT WHEN I I
GOT INTO THE HOSPITAL I WEAR A
MASK.
THE PRESIDENT IS OUT THERE
LEADING FROM THE FRONT.
HE HAS TO BE AN EXAMPLE OF YOU
WHO WE ARE GOING TO GET THIS
COUNTRY BACK ON OUR FEET AGAIN
AND TO WORK AND SCHOOL AS WELL.
I APPRECIATE THE LEADERSHIP OF
THE PRESIDENT I THINK HE WALKS
THE LINE AND DOING IT WELL.
PETE: DOCK, TO YOU ARE DOWN IN
TEXAS RUNNING FROM CONGRESS.
THERE HAS BEEN INCREASE IN
TESTING THERE JUST AS AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
THERE IS ALSO AN INCREASE IN
CASES.
WE HAVE SEEN MORE DEATHS IN
TEXAS DUE TO COFLT.
YOUR RESPONSE TO THE SITUATION
DOWN THERE IN TEXAS.
>> WELL, I THINK WE DO HAVE A
LOT MORE POSITIVE CASES AND THAT
IS BECAUSE WE ARE AGGRESSIVELY
TESTING DOWN HERE.
YOU WOULD EXPECT THAT WHEN YOU
ARE TESTING YOU WILL GET MORE
POSITIVE CASES.
THERE IS EVEN A STUDY OUT BY THE
CDC THAT SHOWED THERE ARE
PROBABLY 10 PEOPLE OUT THERE
THAT ARE POSITIVE FOR EVERY ONE
PERSON THAT IS TESTED.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT
THERE THAT HAVE THIS.
NOW, THE ONE THING THAT I HAVE
NOTICED UP UNTIL RECENTLY, THE
REPORT SOMETHING THAT THE
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND THE DEATHS
ARE TRENDING DOWN DESPITE THE
FACT THAT THE TEST NUMBERS ARE
TRENDING UP.
THERE ARE SOME REPORTS NOW THAT
SOME OF THE DEATHS ARE TRENDING
UP A LITTLE BIT THAT’S IN LARGE
PART I THINK DUE TO TESTING AS
WELL.
PEOPLE IN THE HOSPITAL ARE BEING
TESTED AGGRESSIVELY RIGHT NOW ON
THE ICUs AND WARDS.
YOU ARE BEING TESTED.
EVEN IF IT’S AN INCIDENTAL
FINDING YOU TEST POSITIVE
CORONAVIRUS.
THAT GOES DOWN AS DIAGNOSIS FOR
HOSPITALIZATION.
IF YOU WERE TO DIE IN THE HOPS
HOSPITAL FOR SOMETHING THAT WILL
BE PART OF YOUR DIAGNOSIS WHEN
YOU DIE.
I THINK THOSE NUMBERS AREN’T
VERY ACCURATE, I DON’T THINK, I
THINK THERE IS MANIPULATION TO
THOSE NUMBERS.
I THINK SOME OF IT IS BEING DONE
STILL FOR POLITICAL REASONS.
PETE: THERE YOU GO.